[Music]
33 light 17:33 pressure building is
lights for protocol accepted
[Music]
daddy's listening can you say hi and how
big are you I mean can you tell daddy
how big you are
are you so big your brain and can you
sing but singing how about I miss you
and I love you I love you daddy
allow me daddy and I can't wait to see
you can you say see you hon yong-pan
fine
[Music]
this is UNSC belacan echo 216 can you
hear me this is Uranus
[Music]
[Music]
looks like the main power cells are
fried I will shut down triggering
survival mode I'm going to try to
overwrite
okay you can hear me in there
I hope you're ready please don't die
Oh welcome back chief
i rerouted what needle power ahead into
your suit hmm looks like there's a
problem with a servos in your hands stay
calm
you've been out there a while I know I
saw something in here to check your
armors Diagnostics
oh you see there big guy you're not
status report status report what there's
something you need to see chief
we lost
lost everything there's nothing left for
us
in four years
[Music]
just nothing
not again we need to run
no we need to fight
get ready
I chose you because you were special
[Music]
I knew we would be perfect together
and I was right
[Music]
you